[Music]
certain foods remind me of a very
specific time in my life and one of
those foods is um our i should say the
cupcakes from
a little bakery in new york called
magnolia yum yum they were so good but
they were they i think they were on they
were featured on sex in the city maybe
or on some show
and then they just blew up in popularity
i lived not too far from there in my in
my earlier time in my 20s and after they
became popular there were lines around
the corner from magnolia and i
associated with a very specific time in
new york it was a fun time in my life
but um
i remember being so giddy to get those
cupcakes and there was something fun
even about standing in the line because
you knew you were in a line with like
people who shared this thing with you
this thing that you really loved
pre-social media too yeah it was wasn't
it
oh yeah yeah yeah that that it was able
to take off pretty i guess that happens
a lot more now with social media because
people say oh go to this place or
whatever but it was
yeah it was like a viral hit before
there were viral hits it was a yeah
there was a thing before there were so
many things now things are more common i
think but ugh you know what i want right
now a cupcake yes but you know what i
actually prefer the ones you make at
home the the like duncan hines the
what agree to disagree oh really those
are great those are great too but for me
my one complaint with magnolia is that
icing was too sweet i used to have to
cut the icing in like half hmm anyway
chew on that
so to speak yeah i wish i had now i want
to you know both want a magnolia
cupcakes life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i am
your now slightly hungry host
justin long life
[Music]
and with me as always is my
sweet teeth how do you describe someone
with more than one no you can't have
sweet teeth it's a sweet tooth no people
with a sweet tooth aren't people who
just don't want to i know that was
really dumb should we start over no
yeah you love this
um
you prefer magnolia cupcakes to
i think it was a much much
higher quality cupcake than a with a
cake than like a box
i love those but don't get me wrong
duncan heinz the vanilla with the
chocolate the best i think of the four
permutations vanilla permutations
vanilla cake chocolate cake vanilla
frosting chocolate frosting what is your
favorite combination question well with
magnolia it was vanilla vanilla really
yeah but with the box ones it's vanilla
chocolate but i also you know the
magnolia one i liked was the red i got
really into the red
red velvet chalk the the one with the
like slightly cream cheese and i don't
like cream cheese but that cream cheese
you ate a lot of those you know it
really a lot of them it continues to
astonish me that you're 150 pounds i ate
them after eating like crappy like
generous chicken from beers and oh so
many beers you must have the world's
fastest metabolism
i know i i look at some of those and and
the interesting thing about the enacter
my myself is that i can see
myself now in like existing in in states
of my life you know on t you know and
like he's sometimes i'll watch something
a movie will be on and i'll be like god
i remember clearly eating crap during
that time and like drinking and yet i
was so handsome not handsome just like
thin you're still thin yeah i'm still
thin you're a little softer
why are we talking about magnolia
cupcakes um
uh well in my muffin top
uh because our guest today well i'm glad
you asked um she was heavily featured it
really is her soundtrack in the
incredible the acclaimed paul thomas
anderson movie magnolia our guest today
is the
incredibly talented one of my favorite
musicians
amy mann
man i see i said her name properly i
think you yelled it well i yelled it
because i'm excited but i i held the end
because she has two ends in man you
didn't hold the e's and amy
that's true [ __ ] of amy mann
uh she is great i've been listening to
her since i was in high school i think i
discovered she was in a band called um
till tuesday in in the 80s and i think i
discovered them in high school but i was
i'd be or college but i became such a
fan of hers from that and then of course
she did the soundtrack for magnolia and
then she did a great solo album she has
an incredible solo career and she's got
a new album out so we're going to talk
about that and if anyone hasn't seen
magnolia you should
definitely see it i it took me a long i
was like really late oh you were
partying you you showed it to me
remember recently maybe well a couple
years ago three years ago i know but
recently you know in relation to how
long it's been out yeah i couldn't
believe how long it took me like 18
years to watch that movie and wow yeah
did not disappoint it's incredible as is
the soundtrack i feel like they're
equally incredible oh man so definitely
oh man oh no man i say that a lot so
definitely check out that movie yeah
both for the movie and the music in it
it's one of philip it's one of philip
seymour hoffman's best performances
because he's so different people think
of him as like um you know such a
oddball character chameleon actor but in
this he's just he is like the embodiment
of empathy and and compassion he's such
a
it's such a beautiful
compassionate performance character
jason robarts is laughing oh yeah yeah
last film yeah and tom cruise is
incredible oh my god
the whole movie oh man
i think it's one of the best yeah
it's so good i want to watch it now but
a lot of i mean she so much of that
movie is is her um incredible
incredible soundtrack and so she wrote a
lot of original songs for it she talks
about how some of those songs were um
how paul thomas anderson discovered
her and and not discovered her but uh
decided to have her do that and i was so
curious because again it was just such
an indelible uh movie for me and you had
never met her correct no i never met her
um
and we also talked about big lebowski
she's one of the characters and people
but another favorite that's right
another favorite of the worlds
um and so it's just somebody i've always
been so curious about so i was so
excited to do this and i hope you're
excited to listen i'm gonna do it good
i am too to hear it again um here it is
my um my meeting my my introduction to
one of my favorites
the great amy man
life could be a dream
[Music]
where are you i'm in uh my guest room
the guest room the guest room gets the
good wallpaper
yeah how nice it's like a jungle i'm for
our listeners i'll describe it looks
like a um like a canopy like a uh
foliage um
are those roses
you know what i think they are hibiscus
good good good eye
good
wallpaper flower identification
well that's the one thing i'm really
good at uh i um it's funny i have a
similarly ornate um
like botanical wallpaper and um
it always brings i i try to actually
avoid it because
it i always end up spending or people
spend like the first couple of minutes
of a zoom
dissecting it and you know talking about
it and it's it's slightly embarrassing
because it's so ornate it's i mean it's
not dissimilar to yours just so cool and
now i find myself well you know it's uh
it's nice to give the zoom viewer
a little something to look at
i do you have to think about the zoom
viewer that's the primary you know
because if you do it in front of a
bookcase
they're going to be
uh distracted trying to figure out what
books you have
or is it i mean are was it set up
deliberately to show off that you have
you know taste and authors like you know
certain you you read uh
dostoyevsky or whatever it is yeah my my
junk books are all in the basement okay
um
well i'm i'm i'm so grateful to you for
being on this because i uh
i've i've been such a fan of yours for
so long and i
what is your relationship with that like
how how does that sit with you when
somebody tells you they
enjoy what you do i mean it's
obviously very nice but also you never
know exactly what to say you know
yes you don't want to you don't want to
seem like you're trying to prolong the
like i know
the top three songs um
i discovered you through um and i wonder
if other people how many people have
this experience where um
it was on until tuesday was on a
compilation of like 80s i just went you
know as a teenager i was going through
like a real 80s phase and it had just
been the 80s and um
and that led me to uh all of your other
songs which which i i really j for jules
and all of them that i i would listen to
ad nauseum i mean i it was one of those
cuts your albums deep cuts yeah um
uh coming up i won't
promise myself i wouldn't sing any of
them now you have to sing at least one
line from each song that you mentioned
that's part of the i mean that's that's
uh that's
the cornerstone of your show right that
that's what i do i i try to make people
feel as uncomfortable as possible um and
by over complimenting them and um and
then proving that i improving my my
fandom um but i i
and then of course magnolia i i
your work has been like um you've been
with me for a year for decades now like
you've been on regular rotations i've
been hearing your voice uh and once this
is very very nice to hear thank you
well
glad i get to
i'm glad i get to thank you for it
because it's been it truly has been like
a wonderful part of my life and um but
what
what what is that i wonder what that is
like because as an actor it's you know
people see things or they
but but you are
con
your art is constantly with in my case
um with people it's a part of people's
lives is it um
was that an impetus that you had to do
what you do now i mean did you set out
with intentions like that or is that too
lofty i don't think so i mean you know
when you're young you just have like a
vague idea of
of what anything means really you know
and
and uh you know i i wasn't one of those
people who was born with a lot of
musical talent like music was a real
mystery to me i couldn't
you know i didn't i didn't have like a
great ear i couldn't sort of figure out
how to play songs on the guitar yeah you
know like i needed instruction but i
mean i just think some people are more
of a slow burn and
and they kind of need a structure
to you know like once i i i went to this
music school called berkeley college of
music
and i did i went to like a summer
session first because honestly i
literally knew so little about music
that i would never i would have never
been accepted to that school but
but in in the summer session i worked so
hard that you know that then they accept
me into the into the regular school
[Music]
amy was it that you were just so drawn
to music i mean you were you'd love to
listen to it and therefore you wanted to
participate in it
some i wasn't uh
i wasn't kind of an overarching fan of
everything i there were there would be a
a handful of things that i really you
know i'm one of those people who finds
one song and then plays it over and over
and over
so yeah you know i knew that it
i knew that music kind of
got to me in a particular way and i just
had an idea that i was a big believer in
in learning and i had an idea that if i
learned about music maybe then i would
know if i had
any talent like if i took some lessons
and you know
that that would maybe help sort of
unlock something and you know and i
think it i think it did like
obviously yeah you know sure but
learning about about music theory gave
me a structure that then i could be
creative on top of
oh okay and and so was it um was it also
that you had things to say i mean as a
young as a a teenager let's say is that
when you is that when it really started
in your teenage years that you um got
serious about it that you were really
drawn to it yeah i and i had tried to
write songs you know before i went to
berkeley i had tried to write songs and
they were
just terrible i mean i think you know
you
missing music is interesting because
like i
you know like every teenager has
something to say but uh but i was the
kind of teenager who didn't
want who like didn't even know what it
was like you know that
that my
my personality was so about just trying
to cover up who i really was but then
but then i think like music kind of
gives you an outlet to write about
things that
that you relate to the subtext but don't
but but the text is not necessarily
exact so you
you can be revealing but also not like
show your entire hand
oh that makes perfect sense it's almost
um i think acting is similar i mean you
can
there's a character element too to it
that you can tell a story um
the subjects of which like you said is
very relatable um that's why i like i
just like taylor swift songs i listen to
a lot of i love female artists i think
for that reason um i don't always relate
to the obviously the female perspective
or experience but um
but the the truth in it i do and i found
that about you know that that definitely
applies to your your music i and i felt
that as a teenager i think that's why i
fell in love with music as a teenager um
because those songs would speak to a
true a truth that i that i could yeah
and sometimes you don't even know that
you feel a certain thing until you're
listening to something and music really
is
you know has a weird kind of magic where
you
you feel with like it makes you feel
something and
then you're like i didn't even know i
was sad in that way or i didn't even
know you know yes
that i had a long lost love that i could
tap in or love the idea these ideas that
you hear about and then you start
applying them to
real world you start falling in love you
start meeting people you start seeing
the world um differently yeah i i that's
another thing i love about your music
and music in general is that i can then
rediscover songs through new experiences
through the wisdom of age you know um
i i you know falling in love you can
it colors all the song a lot of those
love songs that that you always i that i
always enjoyed but now that speak to a
real
truth that speak to a reality and i
think that there's
songs that are written
you know
that are they're written like where
people are really writing from their own
truth or their own experience
you know like actual feelings and not
just trying to kind of construct a song
that would be a hit um yeah you know i
remember being a kid and listening to
certain things and and just like having
it hint at this grown-up world that you
know like there was a rod stewart song
called maggie may that
that
yeah yeah it's like his relationship
with an older woman and it's just like
what is this world that you are like
yeah he runs off for this woman or like
you know like he does he has to leave
school and like what is happening
there's just a lot going on
or lola i mean i remember hearing the
king song lola and
or any david bowie song good god what a
world what a cause i grew up in a very
like provincial suburban town you know
and so this was a way to experience the
world that i that was uh opening up to
me um and dangerous and like sexual and
all these things that i've been
i had not grown up with um who who were
your
who were the people that really unlocked
that for you i mean who were the the
groups the bands was it
joni was it the tip was it the bob
dylan's and johnny martial i didn't
really hear much joni mitchell so i
wasn't i wasn't exposed to her stuff uh
um dylan
and
bruce springsteen later and
you know beatles and and early elton
john i mean i loved yeah there was just
something about you know i mean he's got
his melodic sense is so incredible and
and uh yeah you know the bernie top and
lyrics like always you know there's
always some weird story there's like
always some like
you know always like what is happening
uh what is this relationship what is
this scenario
um you know really interesting for a kid
to listen to like try to figure out
what's going on right there's there's a
song in there's a line in goodbye yellow
brick road that i i only recently all
the times i've heard that song um and
now of course i'm gonna forget it but
sara bareilles did a cover and it made
it so clear i mean sometimes you hear
like well i'd love to talk to you about
covers because you've done some of my
favorites uh you mentioned the beatles
um but there but there are certain lines
there's certain lyrics that are are more
clearly uh
you know amplified
it was it would the dogs are beginning
to grow
dogs of society howl yeah dog dogs
yeah um
yeah um but you hear them again and when
somebody else sings them you hear them a
little bit more clearly but yeah god
those lyrics uh so he that was
that was one of the
were the where was it that music that
then
uh inspired you to want to write your
own was it was it as
or was that oversimplifying i think it's
i think it's oversimplified i mean i
think my my desire to
learn about music and want to be a
musician and want to sing and write
songs was a very vague
leaning
in a very vague direction and i honestly
you know like it wasn't this
this sort of burning thing where
you know i just had like i mean it was a
very vague feeling like i have a feeling
that i could be a musician it is based
on absolutely nothing like there is no
evidence so
yeah no evidence at all
but what's self belief
did you have that about other things in
la in life or was this an anomaly was it
just like
or did this apply to other areas of your
life where like you were like i think i
could do this for some reason it's
without everything yeah i mean kind of
an anomaly but i think that that is
i don't know like i think that that
i think that's a workaround that my
brain does that and i have this when
when i'm writing songs where i will have
a feeling
that there's a better line or a feeling
that there's a rhyme out there or like a
figure of speech that will finish off
this line perfectly
and i don't know you know i don't know
what it is but i have a feeling it's
just like this vague
this vague feeling that it exists and
then i'm usually right but like it's
like not based on any evidence it's just
something churning around in my brain
that
like is picking up some kind of
information and
do you have any sense then when you do
put it to music do you have any sense of
what will be
um
received by more people like
of what might be
um
a more successful in that sense like a
more powerful no idea no idea no because
i just i can't hear
i can you know like i'm i can hear my
stuff objectively
as if it were somebody else's but it's
always my ear and i just and i don't
think that i
i i don't think my taste is necessarily
a populist taste you know like i don't
think that i
i mean you could play me 20 songs and i
wouldn't necessarily be able to pick out
the one that was going to be the big hit
yeah i think i think my taste is
probably just a little left of center i
don't know it's hard to say well well
it's interesting i mean specifically
with till tuesday uh with with
you know song like voices carry i
you know which was my introduction to to
till tuesday and one that you often see
on like compilations and stuff but i
remember when i started then listening
to
i
i couldn't really discern
why one should be a hit over the others
to me they were all so many of them were
great and infectious and
you know i would listen to them and like
i said constantly and and to the point
where voices carry was maybe even
further down on the listening rotation
so
was that a surprise to you that that one
is a huge surprise it was a huge
surprise it was a bit of an anomaly
because we were
we were doing kind of
like post new wavy
funk that was more our
thing because we were more listening to
to
r b bands like the gap band that was or
you know chic so that that was more or
influenced that i could sing like that
like the vocal is
definitely this sort of punky vocal
on top of that uh bed of music but
uh so that so voices carry was kind of
an uh anomaly for us um
at that point and and uh we had people
coming up to us after shows saying
picking out that song and that was not a
song i would have ever
yeah
you know i mean i guess who knows how
something hits somebody it just you know
i couldn't really tell
yeah so so um
but what was it like when you were
when that did then become it did it did
it ever feel like it had gotten away
from you when something does become that
successful when when you have let's say
a hit what is that experience like as an
artist as somebody who is
you know like you said you have no
discernible way of
knowing that that should you you have no
connection to that that that song is
being special
um
what is it like then to have that become
the popular one or apoc i mean as far as
the song goes that was
you know i mean that was fine like i you
know i didn't
i liked it it wasn't that i had any
objection to it i i think more just the
uh you know we were one of the first
bands to really
be uh
pushed by mtv mtv was like very very new
and um
and so we became very visible really
quickly and
you know
and in our
you know fame we didn't last that long
but but when it did it was way out of
proportion to him like we weren't we
were completely poor like we were not
making any weird
uh you know we didn't get any money from
the record company yeah
yeah really
so
you know we were living on like
150 dollars a week
oh yeah even after being played
regularly on tv yeah we've been having
yeah so we were living in these dumpy
apartments and you know but people were
following us home so it was like a real
disconnect yeah like
yeah i'll say how how did that change
how did you then monetize that success i
mean
you know we didn't like i i
you know i i think it's only been
like just right now
um
sony records has
has sort of a debt forgiveness
uh thing for artists that are
you know put out records like 35 years
ago and so that record
is now entered into debt forgiveness we
have not made money until oh my god
the first amount of money i think we
made like ten thousand dollars so like
this yes that's it
no i know it's totally crazy because
it's like the deals are structured so
terribly and
and money goes to other people first and
and they you know they have like these
clauses for breakage and you know like
then your cd rate was like half the rate
of an album or you know it's like just
it's like these terrible deals no we've
never made any money from that and it
was not an expensive record it wasn't
like we like we made a couple of very
inexpensive videos we did not take any
tourist suppliers our dumb managers at
the time we're like we don't want to get
too much in debt like well so so we just
had to drive ourselves around in a van
you know on these yeah it was crazy
that is because i know just having been
on the the movie making side how
how expensive a lot of like a song like
you know even j for jules a song like
that would be
i would imagine really pricey but i
guess it's sony who makes the money i
mean it's
it's as simple as that those songs are
have to be expensive to license yeah i
mean we have we retained
most of our publishing so we do
if somebody licensed the song like we do
get money from that but like from the
sale of the record we never got anything
that's wild um did you was that part of
the impetus for going solo a few years
later and knowing what you having a
better understanding of the business um
did you take that into account when you
then went solo
i went solo mostly because the
keyboard player had left right before we
made the third record
and then the guitar player left after we
made the third record because i think
the songs i was writing were just so
stylistically different
and it wasn't really his thing anymore
so you know just kind of by default i
ended up as a solo artist
[Music]
christian my brother co-host recently
bought or is on the verge of buying i
don't want to jinx it his first home
uh to make it feel a little less
daunting and confusing he's been
listening to how to buy a home podcast
host david cedoni has been helping
first-time homebuyers for years his how
to buy home podcast can help you start
making the steps toward home ownership
um if that's something that you're
interested in if you're headed that way
david can help no matter if you've tried
looking for a home or if you've been too
overwhelmed to even start he connects
first-time home buyers all over the u.s
with great local realtors so they know
they have someone in their corner he
answers questions like when is the best
time to start how do i even start do i
really need to put 20 down and by the
way the answer is no most people only
put 3.5 down it's i would never have
known that that's something that david
would have told you and we'll tell you
when you listen to how to buy a home
podcast i'm telling you if you're
thinking about buying a home next month
next year or in five years listen to how
to buy a home podcast today this is your
best bet to avoid being one of those
horror stories and get an insider
playbook with clear
no bs real information
real information find how to buy a home
wherever you listen to podcasts
i was in a waiting room the other day
and i don't like waiting and i really
don't like waiting rooms
so i thought i know what i'll do i'll
kill some time by taking my phone out
and playing some best fiends my favorite
game and uh wouldn't you know it the
time flew by
and it was my turn it seemed like 30
seconds had gone by but really about 10
minutes had passed because that's how
engaging
best fiends is it's a mobile puzzle game
that anyone could download and play
it's the perfect puzzle game to lose
yourself in because it's really fun uh
the game itself features tons of really
adorable characters that help you solve
thousands of fun puzzles and the more
you play
the more of these characters you collect
and the more you win
the more challenges you face i'm only on
episode 40 i say only because there are
thousands of them so i'm looking forward
to a long future in
advancing levels it's just a really fun
game to play when you have some time to
kill so download best fiends free today
on the app store or google play that's
friends without the r
best fiends
[Music]
with magnolia's i think that's also how
a lot of people discovered you as a solo
artist um was that as was that paul
thomas anderson reaching out was that
uh what was that process like was
writing specifically for a movie or were
those some of those songs like wise up
did you have had you written them prior
to that
and they just applied they said that
was written for
a movie called jerry maguire
and
cameron crowe didn't use it and then
like right after the movie came out he's
like why didn't i use that song and oh
my god and so paul heard it and he was
like well i'm going to use it
which is oh man um yeah what about save
me was that for because they sing it in
the song yeah so save me
well
we were friends me and my husband
michael penn uh were very good friends
with paul and michael had scored his
first movie and he scored boogie nights
and he scored um
and oh he did hard yeah which is a great
great [ __ ] great movie yeah and um and
so he so he had been working with paul
and uh
and just paul you know paul was writing
at the same time i was writing and you
know paul would come to the studio and
hear what we were working on and i would
play in parts of songs that were
unfinished so it was very much like
you know he would tell me
what he was what he was writing and what
he was thinking and that you know that
he wanted a song that was you know
said these kind of things and it would
kind of like a lot of just happy
accidents like where our writing was
really intersecting
uh in you know thematically
yeah i bet and with save me specifically
he had to really commit to that i mean
that was that must have been really
inspiring to him because he he shot so
much footage around yeah i think he shot
those actors i think so so yeah i think
there was
you know
ideas that he got from listening to the
music and you know he he uses music in a
really wonderful wonderful way like i
think he's got a very you know all the
me all the music choices and boogie
nights are so great ah they're brilliant
and michael your husband yeah i mean his
work in that is uh he helped make it a
classic um and and so were you so you
were just naturally around
people in the movie world i i'm also
curious about how you became involved in
the big lebowski another
classic um another thing that i can't
turn off when it's on
like your music um
was that did you happen to know the comb
brothers was that through another series
of just knowing people i mean that's
funny because that was sort of through
paul too because his
his girlfriend at the time was one of
the casting directors
and uh and said
you know we were just hanging around one
day and she said
you wouldn't be interested in
auditioning for the this movie would you
and i'm like what why not you know i was
kind of in a mood to like you said in
the most nihilistic way why not i was
also very disillusioned with the music
business so i'm like i i literally would
do anything that wasn't
you know that wasn't dealing with the
music business so
oh it's interesting
that's interesting so you had never
harbored ambitions to act that was no
and i'm not stressed and i'm not very
good either so like i i but you know i
auditioned i mean i'll sort of audition
for anything because you know who cares
like it's an interesting experience even
if you're terrible
um but because the part called for like
that's how i feel about it
yeah exactly
um
if you know the part called for like i
was speaking in german which already
like removes that from my you know like
my own life and and i'm playing you
don't speak german i mean a little bit
you know enough to
enough to be able to yeah enough to put
you know read the words on the paper
yeah
well it's funny because the character
also has to kind of act like they don't
want to be there there's got to be like
an ambivalence the character's a little
bit like just ambivalent about existing
yeah exactly so
you're all natural whatever i guess i'll
try this might have really my unnatural
lack of emotion was
like perfect
that's what i'm saying yes
um what what were what were they like
you must have been a fan of them um of
the coen brothers was just on that level
was it was it like cool was it like a
threat it was very cold and they were
cool i tell you what was really nice
about it and i'm sure you've had this
experience but
um
you know i read the lines and then they
looked at each other and they like
started smiling they were like that like
and you could tell that they were like
oh man you could tell that
that they felt oh this is gonna work
well especially for them they're so
specific you know i mean like that's why
a movie like that is so brilliant
because
it's all so it's structured so perfectly
but that script um
is is so specific uh and their shots and
and the casting so they must have um
that must feel extra good to have
somebody like the coen brothers and and
knowing that you're going to be a part
of what will then yeah
probably become a classic yeah it's like
um and you get to you get to work with
peter stormeyer who uh i love i work
with peter a little bit i really love
him he's a wild
person
and there was another
another uh german
german guy who who had that was his
first movie also
um
and so
we
got together because
i had a feeling that
there there might be a call for
if we had to speak more german i mean
obviously like i'm not speaking german
extemporaneously
is also in the scene he doesn't speak
german at all peter
is swedish
so he's not speaking german so so me and
this guy got together and we were like
let's just figure out a dialogue like
we're having an argument about did you
remember to bring the key or did you
lock the door and so
oh that's funny you know sure enough
like when the when the day came we're
sitting at this
table at a diner
all right you guys are talking in german
and uh we'll just we'll just be
you know fading in
uh
oh my god
can you imagine yeah
just yeah but you're faking it making
that like good yeah no i did not want to
be in that position so i was really glad
we had worked something out
oh man
how how and and
did that how much did that change that
era um i i guess i'm talking about
magnolia specifically how much did that
change
your career i mean did that did that
noticeably change things uh you
performed at the oscars um yeah i know
you left your label after that and went
indie but was that the result of
any of the success of that movie
what was that period like well the the
record comedy stuff um
i was on geffen and geffen and a bunch
of other labels
were merging into interscope and so
interscope was suddenly inundated with
you know a thousand artists that they
didn't know what to do with
and they actually said they told me that
i could leave if i wanted to and i was
like praise jesus
this is the move i've been waiting for
and um it's not you it's us you know and
and and the the soundtrack was had been
on
to magnolia had been on warner brothers
and i think
you know i think went gold like it did
really well
and that was like not enough you know
for them to consider me you know
crazy
that's why i think that you know what i
noticed with the magnolia is that
you know you know how it is like people
just take you seriously in a way like
maybe they knew your name and maybe they
liked you but you just weren't like at
the top of you just weren't on your
their radar in the same way
right it's like you've been vetted by
the cool people
right yeah which makes such a difference
yeah it's really ties uh
and and creatively too then you're
allowed to like grow and you're allowed
to try things um
and is that kind of what led into
another great soundtrack god one of my
favorites magnolia and i am sam uh you
got to play
two
of the best uh the two of us and which i
think what you did with michael with
your husband
oh
how great um
do you generally enjoy that covering
songs or is it kind of uh is it is the
pressure it depends the pressure is
different i'm not that good at it you
know because that kind of goes back to
like you know being a kid
you know like i wasn't one of those
people who
said you know like saying a lot of other
people's songs like it's just
i don't know they're harder to remember
because you didn't write them so you
don't know you like i remember my own
lyrics well not i very imperfectly i
often forget lyrics but but the way i
remember is is that there's an emotional
through line that makes sense to me and
and i don't have that with other
people's lyrics so
yeah
you just have to rely on memory which is
not very good
uh and was that the case with the
scientists as well another great cover
uh
the scientist was just so beautiful like
there was something that was really just
heartbreaking about that song right and
that that was the mood i was in so
yeah that makes sense that because you
leaned into the heartbreaking elements
of it to the point where
it's one of those rare
examples of a song that i'd love that
that was made better i think uh your
version is i i i love girls
oh but but yours is just gut wrench i
mean it's like yeah you really do lean
into that yeah they're melodies they
just have so much feeling in their
melodies i have to say
but it also allows your voice to really
uh come to the forefront i mean it
allows your it's you have such a great
voice for that tone that that song um
elicits and and
you've mentioned a couple times you've
made like self-deprecating remarks about
your voice and about i don't know if i
could do this at what point did you
did you feel comfortable with with doing
it i i guess at one point did you accept
that you were you had a beautiful
voice or have you i don't think i'm that
great a singer but thank you i i really
don't i mean i
you know
i don't think i have a very strong voice
i think uh
you know i crumble under pressure
there's never been a single television
performance i've done that i was you
know saying in tune just because i it's
like i get nervous i get nervous and
like you really
i can't breathe right or something i
don't know what happens really even
after all the the performance you've
done so much live performing
it never got
how do you combat that i mean how do you
then go on stage well because
you know because mostly i'm in front of
my own audience so i know that i can
joke around or you know like stop a song
or you know just
there's like a dick around factor that
is that's you know
you can't dick around as easily that's
true especially at the oscars my god if
you were triggered by that by televised
stuff the oscars must have been brutal
i that wasn't too bad and i don't know
why i mean i don't that just seemed sort
of smaller i didn't really think about
there that there was a million people
there
or you know a million people watching or
however many millions well i think like
a billion yeah i mean not to make you
retroactively nervous and that was also
the the year that they decided to
force the musicians to do a medley and
instead of like you didn't get to sing
your whole song
like
like 30 seconds of the song and then
randy newman like saying 30 minutes of
his song i'm sure he was really happy
about it
really well that's that's funny um
well you were probably genuinely happy
about it like okay like
your new album is called um queen's the
summer hotel i'm not telling you i'm
guessing you already know that
uh
where does that title go i can't wait
but where does that title come from
queens of the summer it comes from a
poem from uh by ann sexton and so so
this
this record was written started as a
project that uh i was approached by
by producers to
to write music for stage production uh
that was based on the book girl
interrupted
and so
girl interrupted as a memoir written by
susannah cason over time in mclean
hospital a psychiatric hospital in 1968
so
you know i i started reading the book
and was like boo off and running and
just started writing a ton of songs
and like sort of outstripped the
you know the the book writing
process so you know that's kind of what
led me to like you know make a record
because i'd written so many songs i was
so into this
project but um
you know they didn't want me to call it
girl interrupted because you know there
may be a cast album at some point like
who knows yeah but um and also like it
you know at that point it sort of was
you know felt like more
yeah yeah more personal exactly and um
yeah and so anzac and sexton had spent
time at mclean also so
yeah so i took a line from her poem oh
cool um i i don't want to um
uh
if this is something
you you can talk about please feel free
i would love to hear know about it but i
don't want to
diminish your experience by just asking
about it casually um but you i read some
wild stuff about your own upbringing and
i'm wondering if that's stuff that
you've talked about about your
uh that as it relates to either this
album or just in general if you've
spoken about uh you what happened
between your parents yeah i mean i
didn't have the greatest childhood like
my right yeah so my mother
it was like very convoluted so when i
was three my mother
ran off with somebody and they kidnapped
me and kidnapped his children also
because he was also married
and um
you know so i was taken away from my
father for about nine months and then
when i you know was he finally found me
and i was brought back and then i didn't
see my mother again
so ever
yeah i saw her when i you know was an
adult but
um wow at three you were
do do you have an incredible story do
you have any recollection of it do you
remember anything i do i mean i just i
remember you know we sort of traveled
around europe i remember being in
amsterdam i have these
tiny little wooden shoes i actually got
i mean i know i'm making it sound fun
but i like it like it wasn't right it
wasn't i mean he you know this guy was
he had a he had a real temper he was a
very volatile person she
um was not particularly nice
uh there was also
an incident where
[Music]
uh
i was hit by a car that he was driving
so there you know so there's sort of
layers of like
you know layers of trauma and stress and
stuff yeah i'm bad
i bet i'm sorry i i um and i'm glad your
father was able to get you back did you
have siblings at the time were your
siblings involved my i had a brother and
he yeah he
was not taken i think probably because
he was older
but also like he was
you know like i was very i think i was
already very um
[Music]
you know passive in the face of i mean
like you know i was thinking about this
the other night you know like when
you're when you're traumatizing when
you're stressed you know you have like
fight or flight i mean or freeze and
when you're three like you're not fly
you know there's no
fighting yeah so like freezing is kind
of all you can do and i think my brother
was just like much feistier and uh and
like would not have been you know like
he probably would have found a way to
get in touch with my father or something
um right but at three two i mean what
resources do you have
to especially back then it's like you
know people forget you know now of
course you might have access to a cell
phone or something um
god that is uh really harrowing and i
were you able to then you said you saw
your mother then years later
was there any kind of reconciliation
between you two well sort of you know my
brother had actually tracked her down we
were both in her we were like in the mid
to mid 20s and um
you know so we saw her and we would see
her every now and then i mean she didn't
you know didn't feel like a mother at
that like sort of an aunt i guess at
that you know
like i didn't really have that feeling
of you know like that we were related
necessarily or closely related like it's
just too much
too much time you know you're that young
oh yeah yeah and was
was her impetus
once you became successful
is that does that inspire somebody to
come out of the woodwork does that
inspire somebody to want to be closer
did you or did you get that feeling from
anybody else in your life like
you know because your success was quite
sudden i i would imagine yeah i did i
never got that from from my uh
biological mother i have to say yeah she
you know she's i mean she's
you know she was a mess i mean she died
a few years ago yeah
um
but you know i think she remained kind
of a mess of a person and didn't really
know what to do with the you know the
feeling of guilt and having left her
kids and she had a uh two other children
at that point and
and um you know i just don't think she
really
i don't you know whatever her whatever
her issues were and i think she really
yeah work those out
does that stuff inspire you i mean how
much of
pain like that do you how much of your
life do you draw from i mean when you
create when you write i'm thinking about
this new album in particular queen's
summer hotel
how much of that comes to the forefront
i
well for this it was a really specific
assignment so like you tried to stick to
you know passage in the memoir or
characters that are from the memoir or
you know see scenes that you think could
maybe culminate in a song but you know
they're definitely at a at a point where
i was kind of writing about
um you know some of my own experience or
some you know experience of people i
know i you know i spent about 20 years
ago i spent some time in a treatment
center so
so that kind of group
psychiatric setting was was uh
fairly familiar yeah
oh wow interesting um
and and is it something that you
[Music]
how have you and um how do you process
that stuff now like where do you place
it like i i'm i'm just trying to i'm
imagining
you being asked that question by me and
i'm
you know i don't want to labor it or
dwell on it and we can cut out anything
but like
how does it live in you now that stuff
is it is it does it have its place
um is it comfortable i think that
when
traumatic episodes happen when you were
very young
it tends to
become
systemic
and so
it's not it's like it's very hard to
process like i you know it's hard to
process stuff you can't really remember
you know and then you're left with this
vague feeling of dread or like a vague
feeling of horror or
yeah i have you know what it is yeah
yeah i do actually i really do and it's
stuff that like um i sometimes it'll
just come to me
i just had a therapy session right
before this and um
you know i put something together that
that reminded me of a feeling their
feelings too um
that are the kind of nebulous you know
um but but every once in a while i'll
connect a feeling like an odd reaction
to something or
troubling reaction something that that i
had as a child um
and and yeah you're right i mean it's
really uh
it's that's just a systemic that's a
good way
you know i think also this is why
i'm interested in songwriting because
the process of songwriting for me
is very similar to
you know the kind of therapeutic process
or recovery process because you know i
have a piece of music it makes me feel a
feeling
and and i
and i try to put a story to it right and
that's like what recovery is all about
right that's true um
is there anyone who does that for you
who speaks uh to you now i mean there
are there artists that you
are following that that um that inspire
you in that in that sense
i don't know i think it you know it's
it's more individual songs like um yeah
yeah i mean honestly like i've been the
last couple of years i've been on a big
steely dan kick because i i started to i
mean i love steely down i think they're
you know
talented really interesting really
interesting chord changes in harmony and
and you know floating melodies on on top
of chord changes that are really kind of
oddball
uh but their lyrics are
really fantastic and the more i listen
to them the more i go
man
something happened to these dudes like
you know what i mean like where you
could just feel trauma underneath like
an artist like that's how i kind of i
started to feel about them like
something bad happened to these guys
oh interesting god you make me wanna i'm
going to do that uh i want to listen to
them now i want to listen for that now
because i i often don't um
especially with melodies that are that
great you know like songs that are that
just sound that great i don't often
dwell on the lyrics their lyrics are
really great i mean you know
not like not always tasteful not always
you know there's like a real cynicism
but there's also i you know i mean it
sounds like trauma to me that's all i
can tell life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
hey life is short listeners wonder is
even the rich podcast is doing a
two-part series on the bizarre and
fascinating kidnapping of paddy hurst
and you won't want to miss it
one night in 1974 19 year old college
student patty hearst who happened to be
the heir to the hearst newspaper fortune
was kidnapped from her berkeley
apartment she was kept in a closet for
weeks while her captors made their
demands then after two months in
captivity and a completely unexpected
twist patty announced that her name was
tanya and was seen on video robbing a
bank with her captors the new season of
even the rich explores different
theories about what actually happened to
patti was she brainwashed or was she the
victim of stockholm syndrome listen to
even the rich on apple podcasts amazon
music or you can listen one week early
and add free by joining wondering plus
in the wondery app hey life is short
listeners i want you to imagine that
you're on a warship in the final days of
world war ii you're excited to go back
home looks like the war's ending you've
just delivered the necessary parts for
the atom bomb
but then disaster strikes your ship is
struck by enemy torpedoes and within
minutes you're floating in the ocean
fighting for survival from wondering
against the odds is an immersive podcast
that puts you in the shoes of resilient
people surviving harrowing ordeals in
their new season you'll hear about the
infamous sinking of uss indianapolis and
the survivors fight to stay alive it's a
fascinating story you probably know the
story of the uss indianapolis from the
famous scene in jaws that robert shaw
recounts um it is harrowing to say the
least the sailors who survived the
attack were stranded in the open ocean
for
uh five days i believe they endured
brutal weather
rough seas dehydration salt water
poisoning hallucinations and it was one
of the deadliest shark attacks in
history
against the odds has the harrowing true
story of how the brave men of the
indianapolis survived the worst disaster
at sea in u.s naval history listen to
against the odds on apple podcasts
amazon music or you can listen a week
early and add free by joining wondering
plus in the wondery app
hello hello again
[Music]
um we have 15 minutes i'm being told amy
so uh i would love i'm going to i'm
going to get to our lightning round
which is oh it's all about childhood
trauma no i'm kidding no no it's um it's
just kind of fun uh quick questions um
as you'll see with the first one which
is always embarrassing for me to ask
especially someone i really respect um
what is your favorite emoji
uh the tilting laughing guy
the
yeah
yes yes i like that you said that in a
slightly morose way uh it just gets used
it gets used on a certain text thread a
lot
to create a tone right
yeah okay uh who was your first
celebrity crush oh the first one um
wow
the one that made a real impact uh
uh
well elton john probably
well you know unfortunately like never
without ever to be realized
what is unless maybe you could have i
don't know helped him
maybe maybe it would have been a
transition um what is your favorite ice
cream flavor um
i like a mint chocolate chip i know this
is very controversial among certain
people
i i have friends who are like do not
make ice cream into toothpaste and you
know i'm like no these two flavors
go together
ah
it's one of my favorites i don't i don't
see any controversy in that um
but now i'm going to be thinking of
toothpaste
um
what is your favorite holiday
uh christmas is pretty solid like yeah
you know i mean i'm not going against
the tide here
no no
do you sing um
do you do you like to sing at christmas
time did you ever grow up in any sort of
church or with with christmas music i i
i spent some time a little bit at uh at
school you know within choir and i loved
being a part of a of a chorus singing
christmas songs that was the greatest
yeah
oh god have you ever thought about
releasing a christmas i have yeah it was
it was a long time ago it was like
probably ten over two yeah
oh okay well then i need that that's uh
this shows my uh how i'm lacking now as
a host uh i like this now i want to just
kill the christmas album
yes
you're like not only did i think about
it i thought about it ten years ago and
i did it um
what is uh what is an acclaimed movie
that you're embarrassed to admit you
haven't seen or like maybe people should
literally everything i've never i'm so
bad at watching i've never seen pulp
fiction that's right off the top okay
right off the top
i mean
yeah i mean there's so many there's so
many movies i haven't seen is it because
you don't watch a lot of i just imagine
you're
you run in the circles of these great
cinephiles i would i is it because you
watch more obscure movies or you just
don't watch them i don't watch a lot of
movies also i gotta say i'm one of those
people who can't take a lot of violence
and i just feel like i just i think
that's like
if you have a like a base layer of
trauma you just it's just
like i just can't have my nervous system
like
ravaged for fun
i get it i get it that's why i don't
like those horror movies like torture
porn movies like [ __ ] that
well then then don't watch fiction
that's uh yeah um
uh what is a game show pastor president
that you would want to be a contestant
on uh match game obviously yes the
classic 70s game where
like charles nelson riley where
everybody's drunk i love him yeah i kind
of have charles nelson riley glasses on
right now you
do you too uh well you know there was a
the reboot of it that you could i'm sure
be on they would love to have you on
that was the greatest
do you drink coffee or tea and if so how
do you take it um i drink a lot of i
can't i can't caffeine kind of makes me
dizzy so you know decaf decaf almond
latte oh okay cool um
if you could learn another language what
would it be
german ah okay yeah well you're yeah
which i've tried you know which i try
periodically to to learn
if i'm going there i try to brush up on
it so i can say you know hello or
whatever
the basics yeah um
what is your favorite cereal
um i'm on a big muesli kick
oh yeah i know
especially if you say it in a german way
a very morose german delivery uh it
would make me
you know something like that oh that's
good
that's good she lost her toe now i just
keep hearing
she gave up on toe um if you had to
choose a different first name amy amy's
a great name but uh
especially you you've really elongated
the amy you're you're
two e's and um what what different first
name you choose i've always been partial
to the name dwight
it's not really necessarily appropriate
for a lady but
you know like hey this is 20 21 yeah
it's anything goes
anything goes dwight okay uh to white i
like the way uh vince vince vaughn um
is very good friends with his name drop
he's good friends with dwight joachim
and um
whenever i hear the name dwight i can
only hear vince say it because he's he
would always reference the white and he
would say don't what he would say d he
would separate the d from the white i
mean now
that you're saying it like that i might
have to change my answer oh yeah just
change the answer okay
why you know dwight's a great guy um
if you had a if you had a sandwich named
after you i'm very proud to say that
theater and
williams
williamstown i have a sandwich named
after me it's like a crowning
achievement what um i could have asked
this question without the
bragging part of it but uh
what would be on your sandwich what
would be on the amy man the amy manwich
turkey avocado
bacon i realize i'm not describing i've
described it a club sandwich basically
yeah yes yes on gluten-free bread though
there's there's the twist okay
okay okay that's the uh man twist what
is your favorite tom hanks movie
um
i'll say big
yeah great just talking about that
yesterday with zach uh levi whose name i
kept mispronouncing levy
he was in a movie called shazam where he
plays kind of like a grown-up child and
he said that movie was really
influential uh
um would you rather uh take a time
machine to the past for the future oh
god not the future
because whether where the earth will be
on fire
right right yeah okay we might have to
second yeah
go back into the past like i don't know
1920s with the
see what the you know the boom was all
about
yeah uh before yeah before
pre-crash yeah yeah
yes you know the depression
um are you more of a talker or a texter
to communicate
yeah oh yeah okay
um night or morning person pretty pretty
morning-ish yeah not not nighty anymore
yeah me too um toilet roll over or
however however it happens
it doesn't doesn't bother you either
okay okay
finish this it's like the oscars just
get it over with yes yes
and then randy newman comes and uses the
toilet paper right after you um finish
this sentence if you would um life is
short so
it's because there's a lot of silence
yeah
so do it now yeah
yes good i like that well i'm i'm glad i
got to do this now um this was such a
thrill for me
truly i've been i really thank you for
your work and and your voice has been
such a wonderful part of my uh my life
thank you this was really nice i've
always thought you were such a lovely
person it's really nice to talk to
thanks emmy it means a lot i'm i will
take that with me the rest of the week
and um smile a little bit more thank you
it means a lot um thanks for doing this
and we're going to talk all about the
album um and i can't wait to answer it
thanks amy thanks bye-bye
[Music]
so that just happened that just happened
oh that's you not doing the impression
yeah proudly
proudly not doing it you stared at me
with pride as you said that stamped you
down like haha i remember yeah i'm doing
it neutrally
um i i can't even begin also because
she's such a
i mean it's such a great voice i don't
want to let you hurt you no no no you
can't capture her chill no no she has a
lot of chills she has like an npr voice
yes she does she does
but yeah great voice
and uh like an attitude that matches her
chill voice you know it seems like a
very chill person she does despite i
mean what she's gone through i can't
believe she was willing
about that well maybe
as
maybe in response yeah maybe she became
a more chill laid-back person in
response to the right harrowing
childhood she had right that um that
everything maybe pales in comparison to
that is that that she's been like
you know if you set the bar
there if you in terms of your
um
[Music]
you know in terms of your exposure to
like
really intense traumatic human behavior
um yeah maybe everything else is just
kind of like okay or it's just a coping
mechanic maybe yeah interesting though i
i would never have thought that about
somebody like that it's interesting that
she then adopted that that kind of
like we said very chill
general attitude yeah
she seems very cool very cool and like
very
i don't think she was doing it for
effect but but
so i don't know whether i don't think
i'm using the right term but like it's
really self-effacing really
self-deprecating about her
doesn't self-deprecating imply that like
there's an awareness of
the the behavior that like you're doing
it to to affect a certain reaction
like i'm not talented or like
i i'm really not very good oh i see i
think you can be self-deprecating
without being aware of people okay well
then in that i could be wrong if that is
the case then she was very i thought
like inappropriately so nothing what's
the difference between self
um
deprecating and self-effacing are they
the same um
i think i don't know i think they're the
same thing i use them interchangeably i
do too maybe incorrect you don't both
have to use those two things
interchangeably
self-effacing i always thought of as a
little bit lighter a little bit less
maybe um
you know as self-effacing is kind of
like oh i'm not like like a
like a less
heavy version well you wouldn't there
are a couple moments in the interview
where you wouldn't
let her get away with being
self-effacing or she no like
she said at one point she wasn't she
doesn't consider herself a very good
singer and you were like what
and then she said
she doesn't think she's very good at
covering songs and i know like how much
oh my god
the i am sam soundtrack means to both of
us and how brilliant she is like a
regular rotation oh like
one of my favorite things ever and you
were like oh what
you like almost got mad at her
yeah and self-deprecating i was that uh
emphatic you were incredulous and as you
i think should have been incredibly
because she i think has a not only a
beautiful voice but she has a beautiful
ability to cover i know
and that coldplay song she covers both
of us talked about that i mean both of
what but i mean i'm saying
and
the scientists are like two i think two
of the best songs ever written and like
obviously obviously the beatles version
is incredible as is the coldplay version
but like i think and and this is like
the the highest compliment to a cover is
that i i really think like her versions
of both are better
uh yeah i mean it's debatable of course
but it's definitely um in the running
yeah i mean as much as i love both those
bands i really do beatles and
and coldplay they're brilliant songs i
would argue that sara bareilles is
yellow brick
i think so
at least on par i think so too i think
it might be better it's funny her first
crush elton john
i know i know
that's funny
she was pretty quick to answer that too
it's funny not funny i i was gonna say i
like having
musicians on the show and i and i would
like to have more musicians because
i like musicians but also i like their
the sensibilities they tend to have you
know where they're not trying to
i mean don't get me wrong i love actors
and it's like really fun to have actors
on the show but you're getting a little
sick of hearing how they like got their
first like yeah no but but i think
actors have a tendency to try and
impress yeah that's true and not all of
them obviously but
i think there there is a tendency to do
that and there's a tendency to be
entered to try to be entertaining and
she didn't have any yeah yeah i prefer
that she's just there's something more
honest and present present
straightforward and like thoughtful
because especially the kind of music she
does is a singer-songwriter she writes
like poems
her songs are
so like
introspective and thoughtful i know
she's that she's like she's an
interesting person to hear speak it's
true she was comfortable just to like
let things be or like say like i don't
know or you know and there's something i
find those people more engaging you know
there's you're right there's something
more kind of like where they're not
trying trying yeah i as i find myself on
those podcasts and stuff trying and like
being aware that like maybe i'm not
so this is not so entertaining or you
know stepping it up a little bit like
i find myself doing that so i know that
instinct so
i'm not shaming actors or if i am i'm
shaming myself yeah they're yeah it
makes sense because actors
are bred a different way
than musicians you know the musicians
their music speaks for them and you
whereas actors i mean obviously they
play characters but there's something
about
acting and breaking into the business
where you have to sell yourself totally
well that's a big part of the because
people might say hear us and say like
well what do you mean i mean both are
like forms of art one is like both are
like performing arts one is you're on
stage or you're on screen and like you
do your thing so like why should any of
this other stuff come into play but
you're right it does like as an actor
you have to go on these they come
general meetings you go to
you have to like kind of charm people
whether it's in acting school to get in
to
get into to see a certain casting
director you know even when you go in
for auditions it's like the first few
seconds or minutes are a chit chat hey
how you doing and like it's an
opportunity that a lot of actors take
and some like
take it you know too too much they like
overdo it with try i'm sure i've done
that but you can argue that that is a
huge component of the audition itself
you know how much they like you i
i mean but then i hear stories about
like there are stories about actors who
are just actors who are kind of like
you know they go in and they there's the
famous one is jim caviezel when he went
in for pearl harbor i think or like
when jim kaviso first started out on the
like casting circuit and he refused to
do chit chat he was just like
what do you want me and they were like
hey so where are you from jim and he's
like right here you ready am i reading
with you and like in these big rooms
with like jerry brooke
and he would not do that's i bet someone
like tom hardy would do that too uh yeah
he seems like a a guy who wouldn't
indulge in the chit chat and i if you're
good enough and like those guys
obviously are
uh you don't need well it should always
speak for itself your performance but i
don't know i think often it isn't i know
you know it's it's that
it's how do you come across are you
personable but i think there's something
interesting about that because people
who rise to
the level of stardom in acting
it's it's not just
because they're
good performers or or good at capturing
characters
it's because there's something about
them
that is watchable that people want to
see that's true and i think in that
little chit chat [ __ ] before maybe
you can see that maybe you can see how
like a magnetic someone is
how their personality comes across right
like so maybe that should be an
important part of maybe process i guess
it depends on what kind of part you're
going for like a guy like tom hanks i'm
sure he went into some rooms and was
just like
charm the pants off of everybody i mean
as good of an actress as he is like i'm
sure he had an opportunity to show how
charming he was before he had an
opportunity to show
what a good actor he was yeah well we do
we digress we digress very man but uh
small part and
pivotal part in big lebowski but so good
she's been part of
such that's that's another reason she
seems so cool and like confident
self-deprecating because she
it surrounds herself with like
such cool people you know like
cohen brothers and paul thomas anderson
she's in a cool yeah and her husband is
cool it's cool to be pen brother at one
point you start to sing her song to her
and
i was so torn because there was part of
me that
wanted you to stop because i was like it
was cringy oh my god yeah like the most
but then there was another part of me
that was like so disappointed that you
did stuff because it was so funny
that's rare yeah they're like
completely yeah it's extreme i have like
passionate feelings yeah in both
directions well it's i've i'm actually
i'm kind of touched because if you
didn't care about me and my
me embarrassing myself and like how
right that's true i just wanted
to keep going that's true
so in a way it's kind of touching that
you had any instinct to for me to want
to stop you sang like two bars and
jumped ship but it was like
just enough to be like oh god well
how long can you can you do that i mean
i'm sure she's had that happen many
times where people sing songs to her
song you think
many times maybe not many times
definitely not on a podcast definitely
not a professional person
[Laughter]
uh i thought the
short answers went well the new short
answers yeah i also don't think except
for the toilet paper roll one i thought
that went well too
really quickly she says i don't know i
have no dog in this race but that's
funny yeah that she had she had it's
strong
she had a strong conviction about not
caring
do you think that that question
is
does it make you immediately think of
the person
a little bit a little bit yeah i wonder
if
if a lot of people feel that way i
wonder i just occurred to me i mean i
usually don't dwell on it no no i
usually just get like a mental i don't
dwell on it
depends who the person is i guess
uh maybe that's part of i think that's
part of what makes it fun maybe
i get like a flash of someone pooping
yeah and then it goes away yeah a quick
flash quick flash but i get that way a
lot of times with people
in general yeah sometimes i imagine
people like that i'm and i it's a
version of like you know how they say
like well if you're intimidated like
what we're talking about if you're like
if you have stage fright if you're
intimidated so you picture every
underwear yeah i picture them pooping
because it's the most vulnerable
it makes them
human huh or like animals well everybody
poops yeah everybody poops isn't that
amazing that like the most everybody
poops sometimes
we're in a different key there
poops i don't think min shocked the chip
is a controversial ice cream i don't
either i don't know why she said that in
fact i think that's quite i would
suspect that's an interesting i think
that's in the top i would suspect it's
in the top 10 most popular ice creams
top ten i think top five
maybe top three really vanilla chocolate
i i think it would rival
the third most common oh really see i
think i would suspect it's vanilla
strawberry strawberry cookies and cream
what
not for you no no no no no for one for
there's a reason that so many
like those three flavors are like the
three most presented flavors i guess so
but i think what maybe made that
misleading was the neapolitan whoever
like that i think the neapolitan is
responsible for that
chains using those three ice creams uh i
don't know maybe if you trace the
history of it that'd be interesting to
trace the history of like certain
snack foods like that like dessert it
would be like popular because i i really
and and when did mint chocolate chip
started start like i love the chocolate
chip would it be good to do a history of
like flavors like that i wonder if it's
been like raspberry
i wonder we should look that up speaking
of having been done on the podcast
people might take speaking of having
been done you suggested she make a
christmas album and she was like i did
yeah you know he's not gonna like that
is uh with the letter we got the last
letter we got um
oh yeah the newton mass she's not like
no no
no um
i've since listened to it on spotify oh
yeah i heard you not an ad and it's
beautiful of course it is don't get mad
well when you say that like it's
revelatory hilarious when you ask her
what name she would want to be oh yeah
not amy and she was like i've always
been partial to dwight dwight that was
my fav that that single-handedly made me
i was like giddy about that that made me
so really happy about this new question
yeah that's this is one of your uh
questions that you are passionate about
yeah i love it i love it i think it like
what name would you pick um well i have
carl in my head only because with a c or
a k well see that's the thing i just
worked with a sound guy named calvin and
i went up to he was 24 um really nice
guy and i went up to i was like as he
was doing because you spent a lot of
time with the sound people they mic you
up and stuff and and i said calvin kevin
why why why do you keep calling me
calvin
and i kept saying it to him and he
didn't he was like uh what are you doing
old man
what are you doing boomer yeah boomer
that's then i go
calvin you don't know what is that from
you know that and he was i was like i
kept repeating it poor guy it's like and
he's like no i don't know and i was like
back to the future and he's like oh yeah
and he like was sort of familiar and i
said calvin that's all i think about
when i think of calvin and he goes
calvin klein i said i know but that's
the joke is kevin
and i said is it any i said how do you
spell he said i spoke with the kid my
parents name with a k wow and here's the
crazier part with a k that is p has two
siblings one named carl and one named
carla would sees kays oh okays it would
be crazier if they were c's yeah i guess
it would if they weren't consistent but
carl with a k sure i guess that's kind
of a scandinavian way to do it carl the
k i hear all the time i guess so yeah in
fact i might hear carl the k more than
carl the c what yeah how many carls with
c's do you know carl carl wilson
carls jr
cara
carl's sons all those sons that he has
all over the country with a kid but carl
the k carl sandberg
yeah is carl sammer with the k yeah i
think so
carl bangs c
yeah and we are boomers now um
wow yeah so but anyway the point is what
is my point um
calvin i know about the future i think
that's why i have carl in my head but i
mean calvin calvin yeah i didn't know um
but i said you be calvin no no no i'd be
carl because he said his kid his his
brother's name is carl you started the
whole story by saying you know well i
have calvin in my head
but that carl i have in my head because
of the k i see
i see okay
what would i be i would be uh
i don't know that's a tough one um
that's why it's a hard question i know
maybe because most people i think you
have to think about i haven't thought
about this before so so if a knee-jerk
reaction to it i like dwight um
noah um
i think i suspect amy mann is gonna be
in the next however long we do these
questions
might be the only person
moving forward who
has like a very
clear very immediate response to that
question
i suspect most people are going to be
like
their name huh uh i've never heard about
that before that's true she had a great
answer answer she did i like jack
jack yeah
jack opens you up to a lot of teasing i
think jack long a jack
c [ __ ] jake long jake i go with jake
what's your middle name though that's
not very inventive i know but that's
what the thing i wouldn't want it to be
that different because i'm used to a
certain name now exactly that's why the
question is
did i just talk myself how did the
question be good let's read a letter
okay
from a little sincerity oh that's nice i
like sincerity
i didn't say that very sincerely the
subject thank you for being you oh hello
christian and justin my name is victoria
i work as a graphic designer and i am
constantly looking for new music and
podcasts to listen to while i work i was
lucky enough to catch justin's interview
with jake brennan ow
which led me to give life sure to listen
thank you jake i have to say i was
surprised at how quickly i got hooked
your brotherly banter and goofiness
literally makes me laugh out loud and i
love the diverse array of guests you've
had on the show so far oh this is so
nice to hear i'm making a goofy thing
yeah you are
it's really cool christian can make a
really i mean it's one of your great
skills i think is the faces you're able
to make i have a very malleable face yes
i really hope you can get alicia keys on
she is the goat
yeah
i hope so too isn't it funny that now
the goat has become synonymous but
people are just saying that
yeah all the time yeah and jonah had
that funny story about meryl streep
uh she didn't know there was the goat
but people are just using that now as
the word they're so they're saying it
out loud it was it was for so long just
like written i mean it was in like
the context of i know it's funny to hear
it out loud because it's it doesn't
sound like a positive thing no i goats i
think are really i mean if you really
like unpack them as animals i think they
are very useful and
valuable but they're not the most
they're not known to be like the most
impressive but yeah it's not like a
stallion or a dolphin or something yes
yeah it's not a flattering animal
comparison oh she's the goat
um
but she she is she's wonderful and she
keys and that'd be great to get her on
maybe she's listening what do you think
the odds are that
wait do we how many goats are listening
i bet there's
listening i bet there's a
point two percent chance that alicia
keys is listening to this
oh really point two yes that's higher
than i would have thought really
yes
but now might she might be listening
because if we talk about her enough
maybe a friend of hers maybe it'll get
picked up on buzzfeed
yeah maybe a keys a keys head might uh
yeah that's true maybe a family member's
listening yeah i bet there's like chrome
keys i bet there's like a 12 chance that
a keys family member's listening 12
yeah i'm sure there's a lot of keys out
there why
because it's a family they're using 88
keys on a piano no maybe no i'm thinking
about our extended family we have a lot
of cousins that's true that's true
that's true i think some of our maybe
more than 12 maybe i'm selling a short
you know there might be a better i'm
selling life is short short yeah maybe i
am by questioning yeah
maybe there's more keys listening than
longs
i'm sure
oh really no
okay back to victoria another person i
think would be a great guest is
hi hinz
who
in capital letters h-i-n-d-z
or heinz
he's a super chill and insightful
podcaster oh who focuses on mental
health and spiritual growth oh oh that
would be great i like those things
definitely a vibe i think you two would
resonate with i would resonate with that
vibe cool um anywho
she has any who she has been listening
uh jerry we had a funny long
conversation with jerry the other we
should get him wasn't that one of our
resolutions to get jerry on the yeah
tomorrow is young i know you don't want
to do it now no
that was your resolution but i want a
plan to do it oh right right anywho
thank you so much for being awesome
funny and genuine humans oh thanks it's
it's funny to be thanked for being a
genuine human
but um i i know what you mean victoria i
appreciate it it's really nice um i
can't wait to see what you two do in the
future uh oh wait if i had to choose
between the beatles or rolling stones
i'd pick the
stones and she does a winky face with
tongue out yeah and the
how would you say that like the rock
rock and roll rock and roll emoji which
i confuse sometimes with the shaka khan
emoji this surf's up that shaka khan are
just shocked
yeah not shocking that's the span okay
it's a person as a person have a great
week victoria cool thank
thanks victoria um cool nice letter i'm
of course always slightly disappointed
with the would you rather but um maybe
we could do our own would you rather i
like that we have a new listener thanks
to your appearance yes on another
podcast i always like when that happens
yes uh let me ask you this would you
rather change your name to
hins only hens
or alicia alicia keys
i have to go by alicia keys all the time
yes alicia keys along
uh no just alicia keys you have to
legally change your name to alicia keys
maybe with two s's and hens with uh with
a
an s instead of a c
hey with an s instead of a c
uh
well people won't i don't get a last
name no
and capital letters
um
i think
i think i would change my name to alicia
keys
because it would be
kind of funny and it would also
it would also be very funny
it would also look like if your name was
at least
it'd be so funny and then if you had one
name
this was trying to say before if you had
one name that would open up
a lot of annoying things in your life i
think in terms of filling out forms
right oh man think about all the things
you fill out online or do your first and
last name and if you don't have a last
name
it'll be like this is you left this
blank
i think it would open up a lot of
logistical problems only having one name
me too well imagine having three names
like machine gun kelly then you could
just say machine kelly though you can
leave out the middle name
you know but if your name was
if you you just call me machine see i
imagine hinz doesn't fill out online
forms because he probably has people do
that for him and stuff or or he he uses
given i'm sure he was given a name
but what is poor elon musk's kid poor
that's funny it's the last time he'll
ever be called poor elon musk's kid but
what is that kid going to do because of
his
name
just like all these different symbols
and
that is maybe the most problematic name
possible i mean you talk about setting
him up for like difficult he'll probably
have help people probably exact that and
he probably has a name
a legal name right for those purposes
i'm sure elon musk thought of that
are you yeah elon musk strikes me as
though brilliant uh narcissist who isn't
necessarily
um thinking about
the travails of his offspring
his the future the future potential
travails i should say of his offspring
doesn't he strike you that way he like
he's really just about himself um
[Music]
yeah but he's so smart i would imagine
that okay but but i'm saying that that i
would imagine he might have planned for
things like that he might have thought
through that like i don't think that's
that kind of brain i don't think it's an
intelligence issue i think it's a
selfishness mm-hmm
i think he's self-centered but he would
have had to fill out forms for his kid
right i mean like if it is that he is
people doing all that he doesn't fill
out forms elon musk when he travels are
we talking about the same elon musk but
what about when he i guess he flies
privately of course right right he's got
like 100 billion dollars right he
doesn't fly on delta
um shout out to delta he flies with his
jet pack you're right you're right he's
like tony stark that's that's true
anyway uh well maybe future guests
of the show hopefully he doesn't listen
yeah i think he likes doing podcasts and
stuff well that'd be great yeah
so um
anyway if you're a musk if you're in the
musk family or the keys family please
pass along the invitation yeah and uh
hit us up life is short at wondering.com
yes and thank you victoria for your um
letter and for all the kind words and
and amy mann yeah man for your years of
awesome music yeah truly i'm you know
i'm really glad i got to thank her for
that it's one of the reasons i love
doing the show like people i admire like
that getting to personally thank them
check out amy mann's all her work and
magnolia if you haven't seen it but her
latest album is called queens of the
summer hotel yes queens yes
thanks for listening everyone and see
you next week life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and you also have a
producer vibe to you christian lawn
another producer we have is katie fee
allen and megan v monaco and senior
producer is michelle miche lanz and the
audio engineer is the um sergio enriquez
and the executive producer vibes on this
one provided by marshall louis
for a company wondering
[Music]
i know that's probably why
you know why
it makes their waist look smaller and
the boobs out and their butt goes
backwards wow
it's a good angle
that's a good point
um that's true you're right it does all
those things all the things but doesn't
it look forced
but they'd rather but they'll make that
sacrifice in order to accentuate their
body is he right
um
it does do that
there are better ways to do it
that is one of they're taking so many
you